hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am very excited
to watch the resident evil
showcase naturally i'm recording this
because i couldn't watch it live it is
during my work day
um but i'm a huge fan of resident evil
uh survival horror is my favorite genre
of video games still to this day and
i've been really loving the direction
the franchise is uh headed in
i was originally a bit of a skeptic with
resident evil 7 uh changing the camera
perspective and then i played the game
and they totally approved me wrong and
then enjoyed all the dlc as well so
uh i'm watching this from the
playstation channel it was streamed live
for me four hours ago and i have not
seen
anything no spoils at all um
it's half an hour long let's do it
no the place is full of nothing but
blood and death
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here
wow wow ethan winters what the hell was
that oh
let's see what you're really made of
ethanol
[Music]
did we just see a part where lady d is
dragging you by chains
hey everyone brittany welcome to the
second resident evil showcase
she's a friend of mine and also very
pregnant right now i'm so excited to be
your guy through today's experience
we're going to hear from the resident
evil team today and they have so much
new content for you
another trailer new game play and more
news for resident evil village which is
right around the corner it is coming to
us on may 7th
very exciting also be sharing the latest
on the 25th anniversary of the series
and some fun surprises that go along
with that so stay tuned
to kick us off i have the honor of
introducing june takeuchi the executive
producer of the franchise thanks
brittany appreciate it
seriously she's really pregnant still
out here killing it they cut out her
very pregnant stomach
hi i'm june takeuchi executive producer
on resident evil
due to your continued support the
franchise has reached its 25th
anniversary
thank you so much 25 whole years
supported by so many of our fans when i
look back over the years and think about
when we first started this project with
shinji mikami
i never would have imagined that it
would turn into such a long-lasting
friend some rocky bits in the middle of
the resident evil franchise i want to
see the series continue
top to bottom now we've prepared the
latest trailer for our upcoming title
resident evil village it's a game
jam-packed full of entertainment and
horror
and it has a huge brand and it has one
of our biggest tips
when you play well then without further
ado please enjoy
it's a very different setting i remember
when we first saw this trailer before
they said it was resident evil i did not
guess risk it looks good this is on
black wings
we await the light at the end
in life and in death glory to mother
miranda
i can't wait to find those pieces and
have to put them in there to unlock a
staircase or something
it's gonna be lit
it's not ladybug we're almost there
devastating
very upset about that rose should i just
shut the whole thing down
hello if there are any survivors out
there come to my
to louise's house near
what the hell was that i ruined the demo
by playing it with way too much
brightness because i was scared
shouting but it is a very pretty
monsters
tell me what is going on around here it
doesn't make any sense
mother miranda has always protected us
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
this all that's left from your entire
village all that's left
there is no one left
we can bust out with this
not a good car sequences and china later
resident evil games
we thank you that car boss fights so far
and now let the games begin
there is no safe every sorry fast out
there has been ripped
chris what the hell
the vibes are good get off of me
stay the [ __ ] down i gotta say i'm
surprised you made it this far
interesting it'd be a shame if something
happened to you now a lot of different
characters going on now do me and finish
the job
um i think it had age stuck out at the
end there
i wonder if that's gonna be a theme
obviously
the numbers for village just stuck with
age before it faded out i wonder if uh
you know something about vampires there
is so much to break down there
i know we cannot wait to find out what
chris's involvement is now in the last
showcase we promised that another demo
was coming this spring
something tells me it won't involve
casualty time with lady dimitrisk
that i don't know the internet wouldn't
mind that let's pass it to yoshikonda
producer on resident evil village to
tell us more about that upcoming
gameplay demo
condesant thank you so much for joining
us again today
thank you for the introduction brittany
hi everyone
i'm syoshi kanda producer on resident
evil village
resident evil village has been created
with the concept
of a beautiful yet terrifying village in
mind
and we have poured a passion into
creating this experience for our fans
of course it also has the combat
resource management
and horror elements you expect from
resident evil good good yes good we
also made sure there's plenty of
gameplay content as well
in the previous showcase we told you
that we'd have another demo ready for
you
well i'm happy to announce that the next
demo experience will be available on
playstation 5
and playstation 4. in due of the game
event that we were unable to hold we
have prepared a special day where you
can experience
resin whoa that's a really good idea
here are the details on what need to be
available
excellent sweet i love that
great you'll have a total of 60 minutes
to explore both
the village and castle areas well i'm
going to stream that you're free to
spend one full hour for both stages or
choose which one you want to play it's
up to you where you spend your survivor
horror experience
awesome playstation that's a really cool
idea love to see more people doing this
very access as well we've titled the
eight hours in village
excellent we have the details for you
here
oh in order of wait so that functions at
different times
major installment of the franchise you
will have an 8 hour window to try out
the demo for 30 minutes
playstation players will have early
access to the village section first
followed by the castle section got it
for the re access players
feel free to also stream and share your
play through to the world
we hope that with your help we will be
able to show off the demo i i got you
i got you i'm gonna help you i'ma help
out we hope that all
players from all over the world will be
able to enjoy
resident evil village finally players
will be able to pre-draw the demo ahead
of time
playstation 5 and playstation 4 owners
are able to pre-download
the demo starting today great
please visit our official website for
more details i think i will we hope you
enjoy
this upcoming sneak peek at the next
generation of survival horror
they're killing it with the sound design
even in this presentation i'll tell you
that
i'm so torn where to spend my time do i
spend it in the village
or the castle let us know what your plan
is
but in the meantime what if i told you
there's another surprise in store
any guesses is it gameplay brittany
let's see if we can get director maureen
sato to tell us what he knows i wouldn't
have guessed that
it's my bad
hi everyone i'm director sato
i'd like to take this opportunity to
tell you all about the much requested
extra game mode included village
the mercenaries for those of you hearing
about it for the first time
it's a beloved extra mode featured in
various games in the franchise
it's best known for high speed arcade
style action
where you have to reach the goal within
a certain time limit
of course we've also added some new
touches to it so let's dive into some of
the additions we've made
welcome the first change is that we've
added a shop
in this version of the mercenaries you
can access the duke's emporium between
areas
you're free to purchase new weapons with
the money you collect come into that or
upgrade your arsenal
style look at that like coat of arms i
saw you eyeing that one
weapons modification i think he's
growing on me
rest assured you can expect this side
note to be just as fast-paced they
seriously went so hard with this dude's
field voice
previous installments it's very
action movie epic
you'll have to consider which weapons
you'll take into each stage and how
you'll customize them
with a large arsenal of options to work
with it's up to the player to figure out
what strategy works best for them
they've done a good job of this even
saying the world premiere damage of
handguns
nice or increase your movement speed
love that
all good they can also make your guard
stronger
each increasing the player's
capabilities
to employ your own strategies as you
fight your way through each stage
the mercenaries in resident evil village
is a rich gameplay experience full of
surprises
with special rewards for those who
persevere
if you're looking for an additional
challenge we hope you're excited for
this extra mode that's included with the
main game i'm a fan
it's a challenging and rewarding bonus
mode packed with content
yeah he did a great job looking forward
to it bonus mode thank you so much
for uh seven
if you haven't already heard resident
evil has reached an impressive milestone
on march 22nd the franchise celebrated
its 25th anniversary
and like so many of you i've been a fan
it's practically day one
together we've watched the franchise
evolve from a series of survival horror
games to a big umbrella
of video games movies toys board games
and more that was a pun
resident evil reverse is just one of the
many ways capcom is celebrating that
anniversary
lots of you probably tried the open beta
earlier this month but don't forget
resident evil reverse will be available
for free to anyone who purchases
resident evil village
also good franchise has also included
all of this it's an evolution in the
video game industry as a whole
agree with that let's hear from some
industry powerhouses here to celebrate
the 25th anniversary of the resident
evil franchise
i'd like to congratulate the responsible
team on their 25th
anniversary 25 years is a long
time it's been a true pleasure watching
capcom
embrace you you emailed me the day that
i started working at playstation
storytelling
and it was incredible not that i've met
him before he's a lovely man but it was
very weird getting a welcome
hello i'm ashley swadowsky i'm the
character art director
at naughty dog i wanted to first
congratulate
all of the developers um for 25 years
of amazing amazing resident evil titles
i hope that no matter what game you
touched or what part of the game
you're responsible for you've brought
inspiration
to so many people over the years myself
included
so thanks so much guys and again
congratulations you've totally had a
significant
one my name is siobhan reddy and i am a
studio director
at media molecular she's an angel i want
to just start out by saying huge
congrats to
everybody who's ever worked on a
resident evil game
um you had me at day one um with your
incredible franchise um i hope you're
super proud of yourselves
um and um you know really enjoying kind
of seeing what you know seeing how your
beloved franchise has sort of developed
over over these last 25 years
it's awesome so huge congratulations to
all of you
she's honestly the best not that they're
not all great
a huge fan of all those people
okay hi everyone i'm hiroyuki kobayashi
producer on live action and anime
entertainment for resident evil
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
the series
having worked as a programmer on the
first title and as producer on several
titles over the years
it's amazing to see how far the
franchise has come
it's a brand name that you hear even in
the movie business
and it's thanks to the love and support
from the fans
to all of you thank you what did you
think i'm super annoyed i'm happy we're
finally able to share the latest trailer
for resident evil infinite darkness with
you today
starring leon and claire it takes place
in 2006
approximately two years after the events
of resident evil 4.
a zombie outbreak is happening in the
white house and the president
is none other than the father of ashley
graham from resident evil 4.
he's just one of the many characters
that we'll be introducing along the way
i don't think i love the
design resident evil infinite darkness i
don't know why they're airing on netflix
worldwide
and i have one more announcement for you
related to the live action reboot of
resident
evil filming in toronto has wrapped up
and we're in the middle of creating the
creatures in cgi
so please stay tuned for more
information including the release
date until next time thank you for
watching
another one they just keep coming my
gosh
oh cool i've not played uh a tremendous
amount of that game but it is really fun
hi on behalf of everybody here at
behavior
congratulations on 25 years of horror
over the years our very own 4v1
multiplayer action game
dead by daylight has become the hall of
fame of horror
and today i'm excited to say resident
evil
will soon be joining our universe now
tune in to our fifth anniversary
broadcast on may the 25th
for the full reveal of the resident evil
chapter coming to dvd
this june and in the meantime if you're
up for it
i suggest you get some practicing before
the chapter comes into the fog
because look you have two choices here
kill
or be killed it's your call it's not
wrong
that is a fun game i'd love to play more
of it yeah i've only played it i think
twice
and that's it for our showcase let's
recap the exciting news from today's
event
resident evil village releases on may
7th and a demo experience will be
available for a limited time
each week leading up to the game super
cool playstation owners can pre-download
the demo starting today i will thank you
mercenaries mode was also announced with
a first look at gameplay
this fan favorite will be included with
the game and finally
to celebrate 25 years of the franchise
we have resident evil infinite darkness
coming to netflix
and new upcoming collaborations with
partners outside of capcom
thanks again for spending some time with
us today for another exciting showcase
i'm your host brittany brombacher and
it's been an honor being here with you
again and hosting this event
have a great day
why does it look like there's so much
more
another time
why thank you
is that it it's just going to be this
pre-order screen for a long time yeah i
thought that this showcase was going to
be a full hour because some of them
showed it being an hour i guess it
wasn't uh
quite that long but um i really liked it
i really like the way they put that
together i feel like it was a good mix
of trailers gameplay
and interviews but i also never know if
uh
my read on that's gonna be a universal
one i'm often like
way off base because i think people have
different expectations i'm generally
just like maybe we'll see a video game
cool with it
um and we did definitely going to make
content around those demos
continue to be very excited about the
game
i look forward to it thank you all for
watching i will see you all next time